- [Gary] Greatness
comes from adversity
and looking the
challenge in the eye
and having the
intestinal fortitude
to step up and go after it.
But it's just making every
fucking minute count.
Every minute has to count.
Every minute has to count
if you want so much
because you just don't have as
many of them as you think.
You just don't.
And so, you got
to put in the work.
You want muscles,
you got to actually
do the weight.
You gotta actually
put in the work.
You want a business,
there is no shortcut.
So the progress you make
and you made over the last five,
10, 12 years in your fitness
is exactly the same thing
that's gonna happen in business.
There is no overnight success.
There is no one year
you've done it well
and now you're
the biggest business.
It's day in and day out.
I've been an entrepreneur
since I was eight.
I'm 40 now.
That's 32 years of practice.
Now you decide to really do it.
It doesn't happen overnight.
You got to put in the work.
- One. Good.
- Ah!
Fuck!